thank you Michael
um
okay thanks everyone for joining us or
joining me
um today I'm going to talk about uh
robust multi-valid uncertainty
quantification and probably have no idea
what I mean by robust we're multi-valid
or unseen
what I mean by these things
um and the goal of my goal is to not to
kind of bombard you with all the
low-level details but just hopefully you
can walk with high level ideas and see
the connection
um between multi-calibration and
uncertainty quantification so that's my
goal
and this is Joint work with Oxford Vern
George Ramya Aaron I think I'm within
here only George is here
um but yeah
here's a map of the talk I only have 30
minutes so I I should try to be fast
first I'm going to kind of tell you
about what I mean by uncertainty
estimation and how conformal prediction
tries to capture what it
um
in terms of conformal prediction kind of
solves the uncertain destination
and then I'm going to try to tell you
how multi-calibration comes in and it
can help us try to improve the
guarantees of the vanilla conformal
prediction and then I'm going to
consider both the stochastic setting
meaning there is some underlying fixed
distribution and then the adversarial
setting kind of like the sequential
setting that team was talking about
so let me first tell you what I mean by
uncertainty estimation and how conformal
prediction comes into play
so nowadays we have all these crazy kind
of predictors um like I've just simply
put neural networks but Givens these
kinds of block box models we want to be
able to quantify how confident the model
is about its prediction
um one like the phrase I like is you
want to be able to know what the model
doesn't know that's what I mean by
uncertainty estimation and one way to do
that capture this uncertainty is by
coming coming up with a prediction set
so that it contains a true label with
some probability let's say 95 percent
so here's an example like maybe if
you're really sure that it's a fox
squirrel you only have just one label
but for other things maybe you're not so
sure so you have a lot more labels and
you hope that the true label falls in
the set with probability 95 so that's a
classification setting you can also do
that for a regression setting where you
come up with some kind of interval
around some number so you have a lower
bound and an upper bound
and let me now tell you how conformal
prediction Works to and how it comes up
with such predictions and the basic
underlying idea is to leverage what they
call non-conformal score Define a noted
as sh x y and it basically kind of
captures how well y conforms to our
prediction HX it's kind of for me it's
kind of hard to understand what that
actually means I just think about it as
how surprised are you to see this label
y given your prediction H so the higher
this value is the more surprised you are
yeah
so yeah when I see s instead of square
actually think about it as a surprise
big number you're surprised and now what
they do is given this one single number
you set a threshold t
so that your these are all the labels
you're not too surprised to have us
observe given the um
Model H so here's some example
um in the regression setting you can
maybe capture how surprised you are to
observe Why by saying how far Y is from
your predictor Ajax so the further it is
you're kind of more surprised and given
that and if you set the threshold to be
T the interval will be simply this
interval that's T apart from your
prediction h of X and there's another
score you can kind of use that's
normalized by how uncertain about your
predictions on specific X but there are
a bunch of all these things and today my
not my goal is not to come up with these
things but take these kind of scores as
given to us so given a conformal score
my job is to Simply come up with T so
that it has some kind of nice guarantees
so now we're not going to actually talk
about
um how these conformal scores are
implemented but to Simply take them as
given
and originally we this is the goal that
we set out to achieve we want to find t
such that over the randomness of the
data x y y follows in your prediction
set more than 95 of the time that was
the pool
but just from the way we have
constructed this prediction set now it's
simply finding t such that s is less
than T 95 of the times
and this is basically a quantile
estimation now right
you want to find a 95 fifth percentile
so what you and then this is so how the
split conformal prediction method Works
to find such t
obtain a fresh new data set d That's not
used to train your model
um and look at its empirical CDF of your
conformal scores
and now take the 95th
percentile from this CDF and use that as
T and by this concentration you can kind
of argue that this empirical 95th
percent quantel should be close to the
real 95 percent
95 quantile so this is how the vanilla
split conformal prediction works
exactly
so just to repeat smega's question
once I find T I can use this T to build
a prediction set because I know what the
conformal scores look like but I'm going
to be agnostic to what the
implementation of this conformal scores
are
you can do a little bit fancier things
suppose you have this joint groups so
Point can belong to only one of these K
groups
and you want to guarantee that for every
group you want to come up with some
threshold TG such that you have the same
kind of like 95 guarantee
and in this case what they what they do
is come up with a threshold by simply
looking at the data set conditioning on
the group and look at its 95th
percentile quantile and to use data as
your address
and that works to give these kinds of
guarantees
any questions up to this point this is a
very quick just tutorial on conformal
prediction
now I've talked about what I meant by
uncertainty estimation and conformal
predictions tries to solve that uh
problem I'm going to tell you how
multi-calibration comes in to help us
improve the guarantees that I kind of
described to you
and I'm going to do that by just by
going with this cartoon kind of example
so suppose a patient comes to a doctor
and doctor tells you hey given your
features my prediction on your expected
business security is some number H of x
and the patient wants to know like oh
how sure are you about that actual
prediction
and maybe Dr knows a conformal
prediction so it has come up with this
kind of prediction set this interval so
that the H of X the real a real disease
Theory Falls within this interval 95 of
the time
but let's try to actually really think
about what these numbers mean and what I
meant when I said 95 percent
so the guarantee that I gave was this
one thing to note is the randomness is
over the entire population right it's
not for that specific patient but when I
do this for all these populations 95 of
the time the true label is going to fall
in that prediction interval
ideally what you want is not averaging
over the entire population but for each
individual conditioning Onyx and not you
want the Y to really fall in the
prediction interval 95 of the time but
unless you make a parametric assumption
about how the data is being generated
this is impossible to do
so doctor tell us a patient hey it's
actually a marginal prediction interval
meaning I'm averaging over the entire
population
and the patient might think this then
it's like there's a very easy way to
cheat the system
what I can do is for in the 95 of the
population I come up with I give them
the entire unit into interval and for
the remaining five percent I just come
up with the empty integral this is going
to satisfy the guarantee that doctor
gave to the patient right so that's one
really easy way to achieve Without
Really knowing what the distribution
really looks like
and so the patient complains to the
doctor it's like oh I'm actually this
part of a demographic group that's only
five percent of the population
can you give something more meaningful
for people like me
and maybe depend like maybe she does
belong to all these groups maybe that's
described by age age race and gender or
these kinds of things but things to note
is that these groups are not disjoint
anymore she belongs to multiple groups
at the same time unlike that this joint
case
so but maybe still she comes up with
some conformal score threshold for each
of those kind of groups even though it's
not disjoint
what can she do in that if that's the
case while
um wanting to still give some kind of
prediction interval such that
conditioning on each of those groups um
it's more than 95
for the first group maybe this is the
interval of the doctor gets maybe for
the second group this is the interval
the doctor gives for the third group
maybe this is an interval the doctor
does so although the patient belongs to
three groups simultaneously the patient
has received these three prediction
intervals and how is she supposed to
understand these three particular
intervals together maybe the best thing
to do while getting that kind of
guarantee is just take the union of all
these prediction intervals in this case
so this is like what this paper does
but if you kind of do that this is a
very conservative thing because you're
always taking the widest interval
possible so oftentimes actually I'll
show later empirical you always
overshoot um and cover more than 95 of
the time if you do this kind of approach
so in what ways can we do better
and two ways for improvement and then
this is where we actually really
Leverage The ideas for multi-calibration
so we want to come up with a single
prediction set or a single threshold for
each point such that it is still valid
over all the groups meaning this is what
the conformal prediction said you came
up with these different tg1 and tg2 tg3
and you took the union of those
prediction intervals but maybe what we
want to do is instead come up with some
number for each individual
such that its coverage is actually
instead of being more greater than 95
percent it is actually very close to 95
for all um for all the groups so I'm
coming up with a single number for each
point it's each person
that's the first thing that we want to
improve on and the second thing is we
want these estimations to be calibrated
and what I mean by calibration is
um this and then this is to kind of
prevent this cheating from happening
what we want to guarantee is every time
we use some threshold f of x in this
case v even when we condition on all the
possible threshold one specific
um threshold we want the guarantees to
still hold true and this is going to
prevent people from doing this thing
because you're going to have to
condition on the whole interval in that
case that this is always going to be 100
you also have to condition on the case
where you're used to empty set in that
case this coverage will be always at
zero so and this kind of calibrated
quantile estimation will prevent you
from being able to do this this kind of
cheating
what's your definition
uh so all right that was actually in the
next
so this is what it means to be
calibrated
so let's try to actually plug in to see
if this thing
um satisfy this calibration definition
I've used two intervals
entire interval empty interval and then
now I have to use inner Tire interval
this is going to be 100 because it
always covers empty set if I condition
on the empty set it's the way it's going
to be zero but I want to be able to come
up with a way so that even when the
condition on which thresholds basically
you have used is still very close to 95
percent
so combining those two things it you
should be reminded of multi-calibration
so this is kind of what
multi-calibration look like conditioning
on your prediction value f of x and
conditioning on the actual groups you
want this value to be close to B
same thing kind of happening
conditioning on your quantile prediction
f of x and also the groups you want your
coverage to be approximately
approximately 95
so this is now article and we're going
to assume the range of this function f
is finite
um but
not a big deal any questions up until
this point
this is the main thing that I want to
kind of everyone to walk away with that
you can do this thing I'm not going to
really have time to show you how to do
that but
so that those are the ways in which I'm
going to try to improve the guarantees
and let's jump into the stochastic
setting meaning there is some underlying
Yeah question
in some sense here
so when you're bypassing but if possible
results
how you're conditioning
and so this will be possible to do
without parametricization exactly so I'm
not making any parametric assumption but
I want to still gets closer to the case
where then yeah
[Music]
um and I'm just hiding some stuff but I
think we'll be a little bit clearer in
the later
so
so this is the goal I said I wanted to
do
but once again that comes critical
support private so tell me about this
one I'm just completely focus on this
problem
and in order and let me describe this
thing what I call quantile calibration
error it should remind you of
multi-calibration error
I'm going to define a quantile
calibration error
um of some function f on some group G
and it's defined in the following way
I'm taking some weighted average and
what am I taking average of some Square
thing and this basically measures how
far this value is from your target
quantile Cube so you want this thing to
be very close to Q so in essence this
quantile calibration errors measures how
far you are from the original goal I
said
okay and why is this why do we why do we
like this because if this is less than
Alpha you can guarantee for all Group G
and possible value V that F can output
the following holds true
and this is where I wanted to what I
meant by oh it's hiding something
you don't want this imagine a case where
group is like all Singletons I shouldn't
I should still not be able to give any
meaningful guarantee and hence like you
need to normalize the Spy the measure of
the problem on the
so first in this stochastic setting we
came up with two algorithms versus what
we call batch mdp batch multi-valid
predictor
um and it basically kind of gives the
guarantee that I said you want to give
and the algorithm is very similar to the
multi-calibration algorithm where you're
iteratively finding some group G on
which you don't have that guarantee and
the level set fee and you somehow patch
this error
the second thing is
a little bit weaker version it's kind of
like multi-accuracy where you're not
conditioning on your f of x but you
still just when you're conditional on G
you want this to be very close to your
target quantile
um I didn't think I have time to talk
about how we do this
yeah let me just flash the algorithm so
yeah you're always finding some B and G
in the same way kind of how
multi-calibration works
question so when you generate these sets
is it just should I think about these as
like symmetrics
new and then like my set is like new
plus error minus whatever I think that's
a good intuition to keep in mind but I
think it really depends on the
performance score because it's possible
that maybe conformal score like you have
it such that actually is it always going
to be symmetric
I'm not sure whether it's always going
to be symmetric but that's a good kind
of mental image to keep in mind in terms
of how conformal score translates to
Productions because I guess I was just
confused because like it seems like this
there's like this blue steam style
algorithms yeah it is
just like the function you compute now
you need to Outburst that
I'm outputting actually simply just
these right I'm calculating f of x and
once I give an f of x and the conformal
score it'll tell it tells you how to
come up with the prediction set so those
are kind of two separate things okay
pairs of the algorithm looks like for
the non-calibrated version but
don't have to install it so here's
empirical results
the blue one is when you just do the
split vanilla conformal production so no
you don't really worry about groups this
purple one is where you choose that that
widest interval kind of thing so even
though they're disjoint you take the
widest thing and as you see you want to
be close to this target coverage but
they tend to be always kind of
overshooting but whereas our approach
they're always kind of very close to
this 90 quantile that we wanted to oh so
the data is on U.S census on I think
just to California so and in the
actual prediction task was to predict
the income and then you come up with
conformal I think score I think we
simply use that like the difference and
so you always come up with like oh I
think your predict income rely lies
between these 200 the uh this interval
and this is the cardiac coverage we get
depending on which algorithms we use
so calculate the size of this prediction
set because we want these things to be
as tight as possible
and because the split conformal methods
they always kind of tend to overshoot
um their prediction set sites they're
usually bigger than
their sets
what is that
looks like a few numbers oh because it's
an income so like and I I don't know
what the actual underlying range is but
it's the set size right so I used to set
size but it's I think measuring
naturally okay
and I've only kind of covered the cover
group conditional kind of thing but we
want to be able to measure this kind of
calibration kind of thing too
um there are things are not really
calibrated batch MVP is the only one
that we actually get theoretical Gary to
that it will be calibrated but
surprisingly the group conditional one
cinched up pretty low it's low
television errors
so the doctor now gives us more
multi-valid description interval kind of
thing just one prediction and she can
actually average over any other group
Bishop belongs to and the prediction
each of these groups have received and
it's still about a 95 coverage
any questions
from other bunch of approaches which do
like leave one of environmental scores
of the population
stores
they directly extended this kind of
commission guarantees yeah my
understanding is that they don't oh and
then I think one nice thing one kind of
annoying thing about this approaches is
that like you have to the computational
time is a lot easier yeah exactly but
whereas our thing is simple like it runs
very fast yeah I asked something because
any sort of other conditional settings
we haven't but it would be a very valid
Baseline um
like a underlying distribution uh often
control and prediction it works under
this exchangeable assumption meaning
pass look like looks like the future but
like here's it for any carton saying
that like I got this gift based on your
previous wish history but now he's kind
of a grown-up and but still getting this
kind of gift maybe he wouldn't enjoy now
it's
anyway so here's the setting each time
adversary comes up with I'm not going to
have time to talk about what I mean by
smooth distribution but adversarially
chosen some smooth distribution over X
and Y
the learner gets to see see the actual
feature
come up with some prediction set with
some Target coverage in mind sorry I
used Cuba here before but I'm using one
by installment and then after giving
that prediction set the learner actually
observes a true label
um
once again you can actually describe
this as an online quantile estimation
kind of thing
it kind of you just have to kind of
extend some ideas from this previous
paper looks kind of like you're running
some exponential weights on the group
and the level sets
and caveat in this case is that it only
works for finite collection of groups
although smega Will kind of hint at how
you can actually we have new results
where we can actually handle infinitely
many numbers
so what is the guarantee that we want
um we want the empirical coverage that
we have seen so far to converge to our
Target quantile so look at all the
rounds on which X belong to some group G
and all the rounds were our quantile
estimate quantile estimate was
approximately I of ran
within all these days we want whether or
not
um our quantile was close to this 95
quantile is approximately something like
this once again square root dependence
on the size of
this thing
don't have time so I'll just flash some
of the experiments we have
um we compare it in the IID settings so
no distribution ship or anything MVP
seems to be a little bit closer to the
actual 90 MVPs Dr algorithm and
even the predictions at size it tends to
be a little bit smaller
we also introduced some distribution
shift
and there is some other split conformal
thing that can handle these kinds of
weighted distribution shifts we compared
to that Baseline we since we seem to be
very close to 90 maybe prediction width
about the same
we do this for
um trying to calculate understand the
volatility of stock prices we compared
it to another kind of paper
these are the results ACI is the other
one this is ours a little bit kind of
different Behavior but both of them get
very good Target coverage
but their thing doesn't really give any
group guarantees so once you kind of
come up with these different groups uh
MVP our thing is very close to 90 their
thing seems to be undercovering
um we consider another setting where
very artificial but conformal scores are
always kind of increasing their thing
seems to be actually doing what I
described where you're always kind of
outputting the biggest thing and empty
set kind of thing
um
our approach seems to be followed more
exactly kind of what's actually
happening on it uh for the distribution
that we have the increase in conformal
score
anyway so the doctor can give this kind
of prediction interval that's
multi-valid even without distribution
assumption and this adversarial setting
so I think I just wanted to say
inspiration for multi-calibration
um so it actually extends Beyond this
quantile you can do it for some other
properties I think George maybe will be
able to talk about that in a couple of
days and then now I should maybe hand
over to smega in a couple of minutes
where we come we come up with a way to
be able to handle these infinite number
of groups in the online setting DSM
oracles
these are the papers actually lecture
notes written by Aaron that's very
helpful and that's it
any more questions
for the experience I guess is amazing
quality the difference between formal
and this algorithm that was the
performance takes the humanity
yeah yeah that's what's in the box you
like the big
thank you
foreign